jay mazzini's wife has been arrested and
it's a story you're not going to have
expected in this video i'm going to talk
about what happened who's responsible
and what it means let's go ladies and
gentlemen welcome to coffeezilla home of
the 10 million dollar studio i'm your
host
the internet detective now
ladies and gentlemen before we go any
further don't
forget pump the stock pumpzilla uh that
means
smashing like and subscribing it really
helps the shareholders thank you for
doing that
now let's jump into this jay mazzini was
a popular instagram star
known for his supposed philanthropy he
was always doing
but in reality he was running complex
fraud schemes including
fake giveaways a fake capital management
scam
and a bitcoin scam which he was charged
for by the fbi
now we investigated him and our story
was a huge success we exposed the scam
as it unfolded we have a whole playlist
where you can watch all those videos
um here and the fbi press release ended
up
sort of sounding a lot like our victim
stories to be honest which was
incredible to hear those victims
justified but in the end the final
episode was about jay mazzini himself
getting arrested but not just on those
bitcoin charges
for kidnapping charges actually see jay
mazzini had become
increasingly erratic as the walls closed
in around him
and right before the bitcoin charges
landed he allegedly
kidnapped a person who will remain
nameless here
but he he kidnapped this man and
basically it looks like
uh beat him up here he is right here
this is opposed by ballerbusters showing
the aftermath
of some of this stuff i mean you see
cuts on him a pretty big
bad cut or bruise on his head even
you know what's been eating me alive
about this case and the reason i haven't
really addressed it too much yet
is that i actually spoke to the
kidnapping victim only days after he was
attacked
and we recorded an exclusive interview
but unfortunately
he got kind of cold feet about it going
public and so it has remained unreleased
so to be respectful of this victim here
i haven't talked about any of this
until today but now with new evidence
coming out
and jay mazzini's own wife getting
arrested i can't stay silent anymore
about this
i will only be speaking about the public
record
of what we know about this kidnapping
story because we do
know a shocking amount and so this is
the press release i want to share with
you guys today
wife of instagram celeb with all that
background jailed
in plot to kidnap terrorized new jersey
man who kid
who trashed him online that was the guy
we were just showing right there
the one that was kidnapped um here is
the mug shot
right alongside jay mazzini's mug shot
and this is just insane i mean
this is the daily voice but we also got
a press release from bergen county which
is the same place jay mazzini was
arrested out of
and it basically says that the wife was
arrested on
july 14th here's the press release
arrested on
july 14th for conspiracy
to commit kidnapping not only that on
july 22nd
she was also charged with witness
tampering and
bribery holy crap
so this one she didn't even just get the
kidnapping charge
she also got a witness tampering and
bribery charge so obviously the question
is
who was she bribing what are we talking
about here
apparently several accomplices including
this guy
repeatedly tried to bribe the kidnapping
victim
into dropping the charges said
the prosecutor so that's what she's in
trouble for
her along with other people are charged
with trying to bribe
this guy right here who got beat up
by jay and uh i guess his squad his goon
squad
and now obviously that's a really stupid
thing to do
after you kidnap somebody and your
husband goes to jail for it
then to try to add bribery to the list
and then you get arrested so that's
pretty dumb so
then the question is how bad was the
kidnapping if they're willing to
bribe someone to drop the charges well
there's actually
a lot we do know about the kit uh the
kidnapping
and so i'm going to share that with you
right now just so you have some context
for how bad this thing really was again
this is from the daily voice they did a
good story on this
igbara that's jay mazzini picked up the
25 year old victim
at the 7-eleven on palisade avenue in
fort lee on march 15th on the pretense
of wanting to talk over coffee the
victim
who'd apparently trashed him online
apparently got
hinky okay uh when two of igbarra's
associates
got into the 2020 land rover so he got
off and sped off
in his own car the crew chased the
victim down beat him
shoved him in the back of uh ibarra's
suv the complaint says they stripped him
naked held a machete to his
neck and told the victim to remove
negative
social media posts he'd made about
igbara it says
this was about social media people
like what where has society
gone that social media is causing this
come on dude you've gone too far listen
if you're
chasing someone down kidnapping that
person machete
too much they also um threatened to kill
him if he went to the authorities and
said
that a video of the kidnapping would be
released to social media
if he didn't do what he was told
according to the complaint now remember
just a few sentences ago
they said they stripped him naked so
that might be related to like that we
threatened to release this on social
media i don't know why they would
incriminate themselves like that that's
pretty stupid though
anyways finally they dropped him and his
belongings in the city of uh passaic
the victim was hospitalized with a
concussion a swollen eye a left ankle
injury
and various other bumps cuts and bruises
the authorities
said wow no wonder they wanted these
charges released
these are horrific juries aren't going
to look too kindly
on this stuff and again it seems like
this is all about
social media posts which is just like go
touch some grass dude go walk outside
reset
jay mazzini really had gone too far he
had really
um gotten so erratic by the end that he
would do this stuff it's frankly
unbelievable
and you know what's worse to know of
course is that
his wife was involved because now her
charges accuse her of conspiring
in this kidnapping a kidnapping that we
know include
violence a machete and according to the
press release
this is just in the press release the
victim was also whipped
with a cord-like object and the very
fact that his wife
is being charged with this it seems like
she knew and participated in some of the
bribery
turns this whole thing this whole this
whole case
from a crime of maybe passion a
non-premeditated crime into something
that looks
much more insidious much more disgusting
and frankly
unforgivable it looks like a
premeditated attack
on this man and um you know my heart
goes out to the victim
i do hope he's doing well that said
ladies and gentlemen i just wanted to
give you guys this brief update to let
you know what was going on
i've stayed silent mostly on this
because i wanted to respect
the people involved and their wishes but
given now
so much of it has just entered the
public record i wanted to
update the story on this so like i said
guys just remember that everyone is
innocent until proven guilty but um i do
hope they face the fullest extent of the
law that's all for now
thanks for watching see you next
[Music]
all the time you said you'd save but
what a shame what a shame you're a fraud
are you the same as so you're saying no
you're
not okay bro know your story made up
apologize but really somehow
[Music]
i can't believe it still the truth you
need a spill you proof the greed is
real you can't delete it chill from the
start it was doomed
i heard